[Música]
eu não sei se vou conseguir falar eu
preciso conseguir falar eu preciso
conseguir falar não sei se eu vou
conseguir
preciso conseguir bom eu acho que eu e
que tem algum de vocês nesse exato
momento acredito que muitos ficaram
preocupados neto será que ela vai
conseguir falar tenho certeza que eu
incomodei alguém com preocupação com a
ansiedade
acredito que algumas pessoas tiveram até
vontade de levantar vôo a ajudar ela
pois é com essa preocupação com essa
ansiedade é conhecer nervosismo que
milhares de pessoas no planeta acordo
todos os dias são pessoas sofrem de
algum transtorno depressão ansiedade e
entre outros
segundo dados da oms organização mundial
de saúde 300 milhões de pessoas no
planeta sofrem de depressão transtorno
de ansiedade
vocês têm noção desse número e piora a
quantidade de casos de depressão cresceu
18% nos últimos dez anos
são dados alarmantes e até 2020
será a doença mais impactante do planeta
nós estamos a poucos meses de chegar em
2020 o brasil é o campeão de casos de
depressão na américa latina esse dado
nos representa quase 6% da população um
total de 11 milhões e meio de pessoas
sofrem com essa doença no nosso país é
alarmante né
pois é foi julho de 2018 que eu entendi
e conseguir concluir que eu tive a minha
primeira crise de depressão e de pânico
em junho de 2017 e junho de 2017
a partir dessa data eu fiquei oito meses
com aquele sentimento que vocês tiveram
agora um pouquinho teor ansiedade o medo
eu não conseguia simplesmente levantar
pra fazer coisas faça isso do dia a dia
como levantar da cama e tomar uma água
pra mim era muito difícil
as dores eram intensas dores no peito
falta de ar
dona garganta ataques de pânico
formigamento no corpo perda na
concentração e na memória dormência em
parte do corpo perda de libido sexual
sudorese insônia diária e irritabilidade
medos choros constantes mudança
expressiva de humor e uma drástica perda
de peso
eu perdi quase 15 quilos e foi assim que
eu vivi por oito meses quase que
diariamente
não foi fácil porque eu não entendi o
que estava acontecendo comigo e as
pessoas que conviviam comigo também não
entendiam
eu perdi amigos eu perdi relacionamento
eu perdi o emprego eu não sabia mais o
que fazer
eu não entendia a onde procurar ajuda
não sabia que estava com depressão que
estava com ansiedade pra mim tudo aquilo
era um susto e eu comecei até medo da
sociedade porque era muito julgada no e
mail os meus amigos por alguns para
alguns familiares a louca a
desequilibrada
as pessoas não tinham mais prazer dita
está na minha companhia
aquilo foi me deixando triste mal e eu
me causou em casa pra mim a vida tinha
perdido sentido eu não tinha vontade mas
de viver europa no espelho e via magra
fica cada dia mais e aquilo doía muito
até que eu lembrei de uma última
esperança a religião porque as pessoas
me falavam que a depressão ansiedade
está ligado muito ao lado espiritual e
eu fui procurar religiões várias e me
deparei com mais julgamento as pessoas
também me julgavam que eu deveria estar
ainda molhada com espíritos
eu quero deixar bem claro que quem tem
fé quem tem deus também adoece
nós temos grandes nomes padres da mídia
que tem depressão
a depressão ela não escolhe raça ela não
escolhe cor a depressão não escolhe
classe social não escolhe gênero ela
chega quando você menos espera
ela chega pra qualquer um em qualquer
momento a criança adulto e idoso e aí eu
voltei pra casa nesse dia sem esperança
nenhuma
e foi quando realmente decidi acaba na
minha vida não tinha mais força pra
viver
eu não tinha coragem mais procurar ajuda
saí de casa uma tarde sorrindo
comprimento e um vizinho comprou entre
as pessoas que passavam à minha volta
ninguém imaginava que tinha saído da
minha casa para cometer um suicídio
e naquele caminho estava procurando um
lugar onde eu pudesse né dá fim a minha
vida sem poder para o qual é atrapalhar
ninguém sem incomodar ninguém eu já não
agüentava mais tanto os julgamentos e eu
não queria que esses julgamentos
continuasse após a minha morte
e foi no caminho neste momento em que eu
procurava um lugar que eu encontrei um
anjo esse anjo ele andava de cadeira de
rodas ele não tinha os dois braços
atrofiados
eu tinha os dois braços atrofiados nas
duas pernas atrofiadas e ele caminhava
na calçada cheia de buraco com a sua
cadeira de roda com muita felicidade
mesmo com toda dificuldade ele implorava
sua cadeira e ouvia uma música tava com
um fone de ouvido feliz
exalando felicidade que aquele momento
aquele anjo me conta gil e olhei pra mim
eu falei eu ando eu tenho as duas pernas
e os braços prefeitos
eu sou perfeita e ele me fez mudar de
idéia
eu nunca mais vi esse anjo talvez ele
seja realmente um anjo que deus cuida da
gente né nada é por acaso nessa vida
nesse momento eu voltei pra casa
disposta vou mudar minha história eu não
quero mais ser vítima de pressão e eu
entendi que tudo o que a gente passa de
ruim nessa vida depende da gente mudar
nossa história
eu decidi não mais dá ouvidos aos
julgamentos não dá ouvido mais as
dificuldades que eu tinha para procurar
tratamento porque eu estava desempregada
não tinha condições de manter um um
tratamento com um psiquiatra o sus não
oferecia essa facilidade mas eu resolvi
mudar a minha história e resolvi perdeu
o medo de procurar ajuda e fui procurar
ajuda encontrei pessoas que me ajudaram
pessoas que me indicaram projetos
sociais que ajudam pessoas com depressão
e aí eu comecei a mudar a minha história
me conectei o yoga a meditação ea vida a
partir do momento que eu amei abrir
minha mei e resolvi mudar uma história
automaticamente as coisas foram
acontecendo pessoas maravilhosas foram
aparecendo na minha vida e eu vi ele
finalmente que tudo o que a gente quer
na vida depende da gente e eu superei a
pior fase da depressão fiquei bem
aprendi a lidar com ela
e aí foi quando eu vi que eu estava bem
e que eu queria também passar para o
outro como aquele anjo me fez ele me
inspirou e aí foi quando eu criei o
projeto seja feliz com você seja feliz
com você
é um projeto que acontece uma vez no
mesmo encontro por mês onde reúne
pessoas que estão passando pelo mesmo
problema pessoas que não sabem onde
procurar ajuda e que não são entendidas
lá a gente abraça com amor com carinho e
com acolhimento a essas pessoas existem
pessoas que não têm condições de custear
um tratamento
da mesma forma que me ajudaram com as
informações a gente também passa pra
frente eu falo a gente que o projeto tem
se tornado um tudo todo mundo que entrou
comecei sozinho mas as pessoas que foram
entre elas foram se curando elas foram
alcançando a superação e hoje elas estão
no projeto ajudando outras pessoas eu
tenho casos de pessoas que jogaram
empreendedoras e hoje trabalham por
conta própria porque o trabalho levou
elas a depressão ou seja feliz com você
mostra o quanto quando a gente anda de
mãos dadas a gente alcança tudo que a
gente quer a união faz realmente a força
nós somos uma família imagina se a gente
fizer isso todos os problemas que nos
aflige abraçar o outro vamos junto
projeto seja feliz mostra isso
lá ninguém julga ninguém lá a gente tem
todos os tipos de pessoas
são todos um só ou seja feliz com você
já tirou três pessoas do estado drástico
da depressão e essas pessoas hoje me
ajuda
elas ajudam estão comigo ea gente atende
não só nos encontros como também no
aplicativo de bate papo
há sempre gente aparecendo a gente está
conversando é todo mundo unido
às vezes as madrugadas as pessoas
procuraram a gente liga
o vídeo traz uma conversa vídeo
conferência e recebe as pessoas seja
feliz com você
ele traz amor traz acolhimento
ele mostra que tudo está nas nossas mãos
seja qualquer situação que você passar
pela vida
você é responsável pela sua felicidade e
é assim que a gente está seguindo
ele está crescendo e está tendo
visibilidade
sabe por quê tudo que é feito com amor
brilha e ilumina e vou deixar uma última
palavra para vocês todos o amor cura a
dor gratidão
[Música]